pour l'événement de l'année le combat
attendu entre 4 et 4
saison de temps chez en une saison de
haut en bas
comme cet homme clash ce serait de
régler leurs différentes comme les
hommes des vrais regardez ce qui s'est
passé c'est m
benjamin castaldi
qu'est-ce qui est ce que tu veux
vraiment du penher vous fait un mois que
tu parles
à jouer
heureusement 13 tu vas pour te faire mal
doucement les garder dans tout cela
tant qu'elle a pu que faire des
élagueurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu m'aides une claque tu
as des ses concepteurs
tant qu'il fera beau jeu seront
chemisette c'est horrible avec ton
t-shirt ça va faire des pizzas va faire
descalzos n'doye murray monte je rigole
pas si c'est fait c'est fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gaza
sakai
non
hanouna est mort regarde une gazelle
regarder un visage là tu vois pas ce que
cette tête là tu le rappeler pour le
combat ce soir c'est ton dernier prime
voilà des données vieux
tu attends
ce soir tous les coups sont permis aux
dames et messieurs
dans les galeries
demander de mettre le feu
mais les combattants
on commence avec challengeur il
s'entraîne sept jours sur sept 24 heures
sur 24 depuis six mois
il a même perdu 15 kilos pour le combat
mais elle a repris 25 ce mois ci à cause
de match hier 2
il est donc la bloque il est une patrie
de que trois jours c'est du jamais vu
n'oubliez jamais qu'avec atteint ça
castagne mesdames et messieurs voici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
champion
[Musique]
non je ne sais pas le boucher de serre
défaites zéro victoire 1-0 combat c'est
l'empereur de la barca est pensionné
bien sûr ce soir ce sera la rattrape
quoi si l'animal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais madame et messieurs je vous demande
d'accueillir la ringer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
messieurs bienvenue
vous avez bien en forme bien entraînés
très bien et bien messieurs ça va être
l'heure du combat
donc je vais vous demander de vous
rapprocher l'un de l'autre au milieu du
ring
s'il vous plaît allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la combinaison
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'essai merci à la bande a tout dit je
rappelle que quoi ça schlingue de haut
mais c'est un beau combat